let's go next to our caller from the
five one three area code who's there
from five one three all right David this
is Noah from Central Florida hey know
what's going on today I'm calling to
raise awareness of a disease called
mecfs otherwise known as chronic fatigue
syndrome for the past eight years I and
2.5 million other Americans have
suffered finding serious deficits in
diagnosis and a striking lack of
effective treatments because we don't
look sick many doctors simply do not
believe us which seriously affects our
ability to secure benefits from Social
Security and to secure research grants
we are equal in number two the HIV
population yet we receive two hundred
times less government funding for
research and I can't accept that we know
there are dozens of metabolic and
neurologic and immune system anomalies
in Emme patients so we deserve to be
heard and we deserve to be funded so I
just want to say to your audience if you
or your loved ones in any way are
affected by mecfs please join our
activists Facebook page called any
action on Facebook and if you know any
doctors please tell them they can
receive continuing education credits by
watching the documentary unrest by
Jennifer Bri thank you so much David
okay thank you